Angelina Jolie was brought to tears
while talking to the rape victims of the
Bosnian war during her visit to swept
beneath Sun read more and I learned more
and I was just so taken by how little I
knew how little the world speaks about
it and I felt compelled to to put the
story together and then with casting
everybody from the area from all
different sides of the conflict who were
all personally affected by the war it
was said education every day in humanity
and in unity and and also getting to
know a culture Salaam alaikum greetings
of peace how are you guys doing now you
probably haven't heard these names mr.
Carr is it slobodan milosevic Ratko
Mladic we're gonna give you a history
lesson a history lesson on one of the
greatest if not the greatest genocide in
modern times after World War Two in
Europe they committed the worst single
atrocity seen in Europe since the Second
World War
she probably haven't heard about know
what all these have in common they were
practicing Orthodox Christians but do we
blame Christianity for these evil
lunatics no so we have a lot to talk
about on this week's episode with the
former president of the Muslim Bosnian
community of Chicago
dr. Hashim Kosovich how are you fine
thank you now we wanted to recently
there was the don't forget or creating
awareness of Sarah Bonita this is where
almost ten thousand eight thousand plus
innocent human beings were killed and
rightfully so people bring up in certain
communities certain evil sad events have
happened in the essence and we're going
to do the same thing of creating
awareness not forgetting something like
this so it doesn't we revisit this
history so people don't forget so we can
help god-willing prevent something
tragic like this happening again and you
you recently I mentioned that you were
the former Bosnian Muslim Bosnian
president of the
community during a time when this evil
was happening from what was in 1991 to
1995 to well in Bosnia from 92 to end of
95 but he started in Croatia in 91 yeah
so around that time so those are the
three points that we want people to walk
away with creating awareness
understanding this is great being aware
of this great genocide many people don't
know even know about it right and people
even Bosnians are forgetting about it
so not to stir up any hate or animosity
but to really contrast it with with
Islam also to contrast it with you know
current day events to point out the
hypocrisy and the double standards that
are him because I said what do all these
three these are the key players the
former president of Serbia you know also
the Serbian Republic in Bosnia was it
Radovan Karadzic and they calmed the
butcher of Bosnia and these people were
just you know these people were in
charge of that genocide and they were
Orthodox Christians but we don't blame
Christianity do we no no
so tell us your part at that time it
happened that I was the president of
Boston American Cultural Association in
Northbrook which is a suburb of Chicago
and as the violence started in Bosnia in
April 92 we were involved in
humanitarian help helping our people
suffering people of Bosnia so during
that time we sent 20 containers of
humanitarian aid to Bosnia we also
initially I helped to resettle the
refugees that were coming from
concentration camps from Bosnia and
there were some like 14 concentration
camps in Bosnia they were created by the
extremist Serbs in Bosnia and these
people we help them to resettle here we
sponsor them and then brought their
families here and then we are we also
worked with a helping of
wanted people to get a medical care here
in Chicago in Cleveland and and we sent
financial help or over there also to
families yeah it was just every day you
know working and working to help those
people now this is clearly outlined as a
genocide genocide took place in the
heart of Europe in Bosnia Herzegovina in
1995 it was the worst atrocity on
European soil since World War two the I
mean there's no debate about this was an
this was ethnic cleansing at the highest
level I mean you had the top President
Slobodan Milosevic involved in this you
had and now now you had the other tell
us about another one Kurdish the
international arrest warrant issued for
Radovan Karadzic to leader of Europe's
most brutal experiment in racial purity
since World War two the international
war crimes tribunal has charged him with
separate counts of genocide crimes
against humanity who was he rather wanna
couragous was the president of the
so-called Republica Srpska in which
which is in Bosnia woods yeah and in
this slope and then the butcher they
come the butcher the butcher slobodan
milosevic initially was the leader of
the Serbs in Bosnia yeah the extremist
Serbs in Boston yeah okay
and I noticed you said extremists sir
because this is not against the Serbian
people or you know Croatia or anybody I
mean because you know there there are
we're looking at the individuals you
know same thing you have you know
extremists in in in all different you
know religions and whatnot and like we
started all this is not blaming
Christianity blaming the whole Serbian
you know community but you have people
like this who are obviously you know
charged with crimes against humanity who
are responsible for killing are these
numbers I heard it somewhere between a
hundred thousand to two hundred thousand
people who innocent people who were
killed to over two million people
displaced I mean
innocent men women and children they had
rape camps death camps a Serbs executed
men women and children the river became
a mass grave but 24 years on the memory
of horror is being deliberately erased
and nowhere is it more obvious than here
ramza Moo hitch was raped here at the
villain of lass Hotel other survivors
say it was used as a rape camp ramza
says she was attacked by Milan Lukic a
commander in the white Eagles militia
later jailed for mass murder Bosnian
Muslim men and boys were selected for
murder not only on account of their
Muslim faith but also because of their
gender the women suffered a different
fate sir a brunette sir was the
culmination of a brutal campaign of
ethnic cleansing across Bosnia
Herzegovina in which twenty to fifty
thousand women and girls were victims of
genocidal rape
some estimates are over 200,000 people
have been killed and over to point to
some say even over 2.6 million people
are displaced uh there are refugees
within the bosnia and outside of us now
let's pick this batch so this war is
happening but many pieces the war it
starts so you have you were telling me
that the Serbian army was the fourth
third or fourth most powerful army in
the world in the Europe which third
third now was the Bosnian army was there
a Bosnian army well well it was not
Serbian army he was a Yugoslavian army
ok ok but then later when the conflict
started in Croatia and Bosnia it turned
into Serbs controlled armies so I became
Serbs army ok because 70% of the general
see in the Yugoslavian army were you
know officer generals were Serbs so they
took control of the army and Bosnian did
not have the army are the Bosnian the
Yugoslavian army was the army of all
people in Yugoslavia and and Boston
people never thought that US lobbying
army will commit these crimes that they
did they believed in their army and they
supported the army and people served in
the in the army and they were proud to
serve the army so they never thought
never imagined that this army will
commit the crimes that this army did
yeah so they had no weapons to defend
yourself so you couldn't even defend
yourself what what some some weapons
were available locally but then the
Yugoslavian
Yugoslavian government was very wise and
you know within the last year before
conflict broke in in in Bosnia they took
around and it took all the weapons from
our from our people that they had you
know so they basically ended up with no
weapons except some hunting guns and
some little pistols and things like that
you know that's how they started it yeah
and started building army within the
neighbors you know
with that within the neighborhoods so so
this for this president and then the
president from within and then this top
general obviously these were people who
wanted to exterminate Muslims they were
racist I heard that there was the
nationalism they were really pushing
this this nationalism songs were being
song you know and just pumping the
people up kind of contrast that like
today we see it we see some of that you
know this nationalism like you know
creating the other well you see back in
1987 slobodan milosevic she was
addressing the Serbian Communist
Congress and at that time he he
expressed he was saying that the Serbia
is not getting enough from the
Yugoslavian Federation you know well
they deserve more and then he also said
that Serbs should live all in in a one
big powerful country called greater
Serbia so they're worse most of the most
of the people living in in in debt in
Serbia at that time were Serbs ethnic
Serbs and but also there were some are
ethnic Serbs they were living as a
minority in Croatia and Bosnia and and
some of these were extremists you know
they were blinded by the Serbian
national LT and they accepted this with
enthusiasm you know and and and that's
how these things things started he woke
the nationalism within these extremists
yeah and that's what we see and another
thing he said whatever whatever so their
motto is whatever Serbs live that Serbia
yeah that's what what these you know
Serbian nationalists are believing in
uh-huh what was that kind of you see
that white supremacy kind of you know
will we see somewhat today but this is
another form of that that racism that
this is when now this contrasted that to
Islam when you look at you know the
original sin what we see was that that
arrogance the the original sin of the
devil Shaitaan when you see
like when out of respect when God had
ordered at Shaitaan to bow down he said
I'm better than him you know this racism
and that's the root of all evil so we
can see that here happening taking it to
an extremist extent where ours is better
than your's and fighting this you know
what problem Hamid said this stinks this
nationalism right and this extreme
version of it
that actually led them to go ahead and
commit this genocide to want to wipe the
whole Muslim Bosnian community off the
map right they were not concerned about
democracy they were planning so bottom
you know so is the former president of
Serbia he together with the top military
leaders of Yugoslavian army they were
they made plans and they organized this
genocide in Bosnia and their main thing
was to eliminate Muslims from certain
era from certain areas in a Bosnia
especially in the eastern Bosnia and
along the western part of the Rena River
and that's where servants I was on the
river and saw and then said gutters day
and Zepa and they were called safe zones
of United Nations and but Serbia they
they wanted to take over and occupy all
those three safe zones of United Nations
and that was their strategy - yeah - to
make it part of Serbia mm-hmm we're
gonna go ahead and take a break and even
and we'll get into that next even in
this safe zone this is that what what
recently we had the event with what was
it never forget sub Anisa is that what
it is we're over 8,000 people died and
they were supposed to be safe by the
peacekeepers the UN was there but right
on then they watch all these eight
thousand plus innocent
beings were systematically massacred is
that right we're gonna continue from
there
and revisiting this we can learn from it
and hopefully to prevent something evil
like this from happening again
don't go anywhere right back they took
248 UN peacekeepers hostage and in July
that year they committed the worst
single atrocity seen in Europe since the
Second World War they overran the small
Muslim town of Schreiber Aneesa which
had been designated a UN safe area and
they went on an orgy of mass executions
there was an assault on garage day there
was assault on shepper and there was
this terrible assault on shrubbery
needsa to this day you know the numbers
are staggering 8,000 or so Muslim men
and boys slaughtered just because they
were Muslim
back here on the Dean show okay so we
cover it you have nationalism okay
you're I'm an American I'm Bosnian I
love my country I love my background
also if my parents are from Bosnia and I
thought this is something important
because other communities as I mentioned
they bring up you know certain events
that have happened to them
in the essence of preventing something
evil like that happening to them again
and not to stir up any hate or animosity
because you have you know people from
Serbia or from Croatia from from these
walks are really good you know really
good people and but then you have
extremist extremists radicals in every
you know community and then we brought
up the point that these were Orthodox
Christians and the Orthodox Church
actually is on record saying that you
know praising the Radovan Karadzic as
one of the most prominent sons of our
Lord Jesus Christ the Greek Orthodox
Church described him as quote one of the
most prominent sons of our Lord Jesus
Christ working for peace but you never
really hear do you have you heard you
don't hear much connection back in the
media or through any of the news reports
saying that these were radical
Christians it's kind of like what you do
as soon as someone's a Muslim you know
Islam is on the witness stand you know
it's it's a it's it's a showcase like
this is Islam motivating them and
whatnot but you don't have you heard
that ever the contrast being made no I I
never heard Christian terrorists
it is usually Islamic or Muslim
terrorists and first of all there is no
Islamic terrorism or Islamic terrorists
because Islam does not teach terrorism
it teaches peace and coexistence and
tolerance so you know or how about when
you hear this radical Islam what do you
say this is a radical Islam because
obviously if we're going to play that
game they were practicing a form of
radical Christianity but we don't blame
Christianity right this is as radical
because you have footage right now
people are seeing you know they're in
the church right you know
with the pot with the pre sitting and
this is like a crusade this was like
almost one can say this was a modern-day
Holi what people they would say there's
no such thing as a holy war but to these
people this was a holy war to
exterminate Muslims well if Christians
are true Christians they would follow
the message of Jesus Christ and he was
teaching peace and love you know but
these extremists you know in Bosnia they
were doing opposite of what Jesus was
teaching so they were not they were not
really Christians because they were not
following the Christian message which is
peace and love loving your neighbor yes
yes yes yes you know what was Jesus
teaching you know when he was slapping
me in the face he turned the other side
to slap him again but these people know
me and they they were being unprovoked
and they were doing you know crimes and
trying to eliminate Muslims from from
most of the parts of the boss now do you
have like the the sir because we see
it's very sad and unfortunate that you
have you know you have whole stadiums
you people recently not too long ago
rudder on cut a [ __ ] in somebody's I
think got forty years I was he got
convicted for for crimes against
humanity for genocide guilty of the
following counts count to genocide count
three persecution a crime against
humanity count for guilty on ten out of
eleven counts a litany of Cruelty murder
a crime against humanity here he was
today inscrutable but guilty of
atrocities committed in a war that cost
over 100,000 lives created millions of
refugees and became the darkest chapter
of post-war European history and
you see you you see people held them as
icons not Sigonella kato ASO school
after medici initially or a thematic
unity confirm and rap comrade it's
called Europe's biggest killer since
Adolphe Hitler 1995 in eastern Bosnia
Serbs are fighting Muslims
[Music]
don't worry marriage tells this boy will
look after you alive within hours as
Freddy Nietzsche massacre began around
8,000 muslims murdered at the same time
laddish led the four year siege of
sarajevo the longest siege in modern
history
ten thousand died from serb shells and
snipers the International Court of
Justice indicted that it's for genocide
and crimes against humanity but couldn't
find him the first he hid in plain sight
attending wedding soccer matches
visiting restaurants and then a twenty
million dollar bounty on his head he
disappeared until today today we
arrested Rutherford manager you know
whole stadiums you know they were they
were chanting their names that's the
scary part but have you had have you had
dialogue with some some Serbians or
people from this area who have company
because if someone does something to
name Islam will be like hold on that he
doesn't represent Islam these people
don't people who do it such evil acts
who are doing opposite to Islam will be
the first to condemn we become almost
professional condemn errs all right but
have you have them come up and condemn
these acts these dis genocide which like
we said is the biggest genocide since
world war to say after world war two
some of my own patients condemned these
things Orthodox Christians from former
Yugoslavia nicely condemned these things
and also I we need to also
say this there was a whole brigade in in
a bosnian army that was formed in during
during those three years of war three
and half years there was called Slava
Provost Lana
which means you it was it was it
contained all the Orthodox Christians
they were fighting in defense of Bosnia
oh okay the whole whole brigade so they
weren't with the rather these rebels
they they they were defending Bosnian
and and and they were not extremists you
see okay so you had good I had these
good Serbians who are stepping up
fighting along with the Muslim Bosnians
against the evil that was being
perpetuated against them and there were
some also that I know from a little town
that I came from eastern Bosnia they
were they were running away from Bosnia
into into Montenegro to hide so that
they don't go into serbs extremist army
yeah they didn't wanna fight against an
a Muslim neighbors and and and hurt them
and you know so there are people like
that and that upsets me when when
sometimes even you know some Bosnians
will try to blanket statement and have
that hate in Islam doesn't teach us that
against all Serbian Islam doesn't teach
us that I had instances where patients
walk in my office and you know a while
waiting in the waiting room they will
sometimes say you know all Serbs are
saying so I had to stop them right there
I said look wait you are wrong it's not
true you cannot make judgment and judge
the whole group because I know
definitely there are some good you know
Serbs and if they were even in the
Bosnian army fighting against this
aggressor you know and against these
crimes against the invasion of Bosnia so
you cannot do that don't don't say that
I also have some patients that don't
agree with you and and and and are not
extremists so you know in every in every
group of people you have a good and you
have a bad and about in Bosnia the same
thing that
most of the Orthodox Serbs
were following their nationalism their
national leaders blindly without
questioning them without you know that's
what you suppose in their wrong ideas
and yes so that's right wow that's how
it shows and illustrates how important
is have good leaders how what what
impact you know a leader and with this
nationalism and I heard the songs and
company people up and we see that with
the politics here today contrasting it
you know feeding creating this
manufactured fear right and this
manufactured hate like Hollywood often
say that's manufactured there's a
legitimate fear you fear you know some
thunder you hear but then you go to the
movies that's manufactured that's
Hollywood
so creating it like Muslims are
terrorists they're here to you know
shudder yeah you hear all this nonsense
right and now you you scared of your
neighbor and you see that and then and
then the gun start coming out and you
start looking at these people as less
human and then you have a genocide
happening right most people that do
those things actually they are ignorant
about subject they talking about and
they are also arrogant you know and but
in this case with carriages she was
educated psychiatrist but you know seems
like he needed some help and he was a
psychiatrist was eloquent he was he was
he was his college education he was
going to Sarajevo he got educated there
he lived there and instead of taking
care of their city he was shelling it
you know unbelievable yeah I mean what
kind of mind is that I mean a criminal
mind well we're gonna take a break and
we'll be right back with more revisiting
history so we can God will and prevent
something a travesty like this one of
the great the greatest genocide to
happen after world war ii world war ii
on on european soil that you probably
know about we're
visiting it educating you on this lost
history almost forgotten don't go
anywhere
let's not forget that this was a
slaughter of civilians not a traditional
army against army it was a completely
unlevel playing field right down to the
fact that they were perched on the
mountains surrounding Sarajevo and the
civilians were in all these valley towns
and cities who are being sniped who were
being shelled at red lines and water
lines you know crossing the road
children even women old men
back here on the DS show all right so
let's paint a picture Siravo is sieged
you got snipers there's like mountains
around and people going to get some
bread against some food because it was a
scarcity right and you had events is
that true that these snipers were
ordered to just shoot innocent civilians
methods included the bombing of
civilians first in the capital Sarajevo
and then in dozens of other places for
the next three and a half years the
world would watch the siege and
bombardment of Sarajevo massacres in
marketplaces
sniper and mortar attacks on civilians
and concentration camps filled with
Muslims the goal was to carve out an
ethnically pure Serb state 'let yes yes
can you just can you elaborate on there
well for example people were standing
people were at at at the market you know
buying and selling things and there will
be at one time they showed the market
and a lot of people got killed there a
lot of people wounded you know and but
then they say you know this the Serb
leaders say no those those were Muslims
that were shelling their own people to
evoke sympathy from from the world from
the you know on the world community
world community you know that they will
turn against the Serbs I mean that's
that's complete for this information you
know and then another instance in Tuzla
they also the same thing like that they
you know they were showing a people in
you know you know outside in the groups
and killed and made many people you know
yeah another interesting thing is you go
in and people are staying you know bread
line you know and and there
they'll there was shell and you know and
won't many people like killin won't many
people like that so another interesting
thing is I mean it's a god-given right
that you have to defend yourself your
home your family and is it true that
there was a who was it that suggested or
actually brought up the idea that it
passed into the arms embargo was this
from the the army how does that come
about well that that meaning that the
the Bozz the Muslims the Bosnian Muslim
Bosnians they weren't even allowed to
have this god-given right to defend
themselves with arms the UN had banned
arm sales to the region to reduce the
violence this left the Muslims
practically defenseless against them
Serbs
well when Croatia and Slovenia are
declared independence on June 25th 1991
the Yugoslavian army moved in in
Slovenia and and was fighting there for
a couple of weeks and then moved out
into Croatia and the slaughter of
innocent crowds who were Catholic
Christians started there and according
to some estimates over you know it was
in ten thousands that of those people
were killed in you know in the next in
the next year and then the United
Nations under the pretext of preventing
escalation of the war in their region
they evoked arms embargo on September 26
1991 but that did a great injustice to
Croatians because they didn't have army
and they were just for him in the army
and trying to defend themselves against
the Yugoslav army there was you know
armed to their teeth you know and then
after about 10 months in April 92 the
Bosnia had a referendum and they
approved
to become independent independent
Republic in the independent country and
people that came out to vote is like 90
over 90 percent of people voted for the
independence of Bosnia but some of the
ethnic Serbs didn't like that and
started you know creating violence in
Bosnia and after about 10 months there
was a peace agreement in Croatia and
that peace agreement stipulated that now
you go saw he was lobbying army now
serbs army to move either to Serbia or
bosnia and and united nations did not
disarm the Serb army allowed them to
move with a heavy weapons into but into
Bosnia they chose to move to Bosnia so
you see the United Nations you know they
should actually disarm the Serb army
right there and if they did these
atrocities would be preventable in
Bosnia but then when the world shifted
into Bosnia they applied the arms
embargo on Bosnia - even though it was
an United Nations recognize Bosnia as
independent but they applied the arms
embargo on Bosnia people who were
armless and couldn't defend themselves
had no army I mean what are hypocrisy
you know and 15 members of the Security
Council they voted for their arms
embargo I'm sorry to say but even our
own country United States water for arms
embargo and never voted to to get rid of
it you know so all the things that
happen in Bosnia all those countries
that voted for arms embargo they are
also indirectly responsible for all the
war crimes in Croatia and Bosnia so it's
kind of like okay we're not going to
come to help you know stop this genocide
but we're not even we're going to tie
your hands and not let you defend
yourself yeah and and and and sad but
true whoo-hoo why this arms embargo was
established the Yugoslavian Army
officers
ask the United Nations to to make arms
embargo on former Yugoslavia because it
you know they had arms they need no arms
Yugoslav army had arms up to their teeth
third strongest army in the world third
strongest army in the Europe and fifth
strongest in the world at that time so
they didn't need the arms and and you
know to have arms embargo there is
basically to prevent the people the
victims who they victimized to prevent
those victims to defend themselves
against the aggressor ok tell us this
now you're expecting the UN the
peacekeepers there they're also armed
right there they're supposed to you feel
kind of safe right you feel like okay I
guess this town suburban itza is
supposed to be controlled by the UN and
what happens there I heard okay so they
they ended up getting massacred right
under the nose of the UN ethnic
cleansing Richard Holbrooke called it
genocide Bosnia's Moslems
endure 15 more months of heartbreak and
slaughter the UN established what it
called safe areas but without enough
force to make them safe thousands of
Muslims sought refuge in Streb ronita
and in July 1995 the Serbs over an the
small UN force there and they captured
the town instead of Benicia over 8,000
innocent people describe to us what
happened there I was with the UN wanted
to they were asking for 6000 won per 4
forces 1 / 4 supposed to be like a
peacekeeping forces in Bosnia and they
asked for 6000 men but they only got
450,000 and for 450 soldiers in there
and no country wanted to risk their
soldiers but
you know Holland Dutch government they
accepted their responsibility and they
put 450 of their soldiers in there with
a light our you know lightly armed with
no heavy real heavy artillery okay
and those zones were called safe zones
and there was not supposed to be
shelling from outside into those zones
but the shelling the Serbs continued to
shelter burns and other so called safe
zones like karuppaiyah and Godard a they
continue to shell and and to destroy
civilian objects homes buildings
religious you know structures the
capital Sarajevo to force the Moslems
out
they destroyed mosques they burned books
and they systematically raped Muslim
women and girls and to kill innocent
civilians and to to create terrible
living conditions for those people
within you know lack of food lack of
heating lack of electricity lack of
everything you know Sri bernisa was
concentration camp in as a safe zone
under the protection of United Nations
there were concentration camps they were
not protected you know it was just a
concentration camp what it what if
someone says okay this is war you know
when you when you talk about they
actually had rape camps other survivors
say it was used as a rape camp we know
that women were selected for an
unimaginable campaign of sexual violence
slavery and
forced impregnation the exact figures
are not named because shame and stigma
prevent many from speaking out they had
people in concentration camps who were
being beaten starved tortured if someone
says this is this is just the
consequence of war right they were doing
the baza the Muslims were doing the same
thing have you heard have you heard this
argument yes and what would you say
aggressor is trying to equalize victims
with the aggressors which is totally
that's disinformation that they are
spreading around Bosnians did not go and
attack Serbia or Montenegro Bosnia was
attacked by the Yugoslavian army and the
extremist Serbs who were called chutneys
and they were killing everybody there
was not served okay including Serbs
those who are not extremists and were
defending Bosnia and were fighting
against them who what they who weren't
it's not it seems like it's kind of like
the Christian Crusaders way back when
who did who were who would even kill
Christians who weren't practicing their
form of Christianity this is basically
modern crusade yeah but you don't hear
that I mentioned again again again I
just want to stress the point that we
don't blame Christianity and pointing
out the hypocrisy and double standard
because people expect Muslims to be
professional condemned errs for
everything so also we should be fair and
balanced right and call out certain
things and and and be just and fair and
analyzing these things and we know that
this does not apply to Christianity no
but you have radical elements also from
among some some Muslims right but you
don't you can't blame Islam let's go and
contrast that with what we believe is
the last and final mission sent a man
kind of problem humming peace be upon
them the rules of engagement in combat
when when there was a there are so many
situations but it just outlines the
mercy even you know in combat where
you're not allowed to kill innocent men
women children problem Hamid saw a woman
who had
two had been killed he was angry you
know let alone of rape camps this this
is be the first thing you know on the
day of judgment if someone killed
innocent blood a Muslim is scared to
have any innocent blood be it from a
certain isn't serb innocent Croatian
anybody you know who's innocent and
these things different when someone's
pointing a gun at you coming with a
machete at God and I've you ever right
that's you're in combat but now raping
women sniper you know shooting people in
the bread market does Islam give
justification to this because it's war
no no it there's no justification to
kill innocent people
doesn't matter they are Muslims or
non-muslims because islam teaches you
know it's right in Quran
you know our Lord Oceano says that if
you kill one innocent human being it
does not say one innocent Muslim misses
one innocent human being it is like a
killing the whole world yes you know so
these rules have a gate that's that's
the thing that's incredible like the the
the the Prophet the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him who is a brother to
Jesus Moses Abraham they all brought the
same message worship the Creator not the
creation you know this is the same the
Creator created us all and and called us
you know to be good to our neighbors and
I think do we take some responsibility
here that we also went away from calling
people to to educating people on Islam
educating people doing the Dawa you
follow me
how much account of itself you know
analyzation on us as muslims some
accountability right is there anything
again you can't now blame blame yourself
for this person killing and maiming you
but what would you say for for to
prevent something like this happening
again for external right for the world
to know but an internal what's our duty
you know Bosnians for muslims you know
educating you know humanity what you
know caught doing more doubt what would
you say is educate the future
generations about the truth yeah that
happened
and we should also educate our future
generations not to be naive but to be
alert and to be prepared for things like
this in a future okay because people in
Bosnia were not prepared they were
mostly naive people even during those
ten months of war raging in Croatia the
Bosnian leadership was naive and made a
big mistake with the current president
at that time they made a mistake of not
preparing for the war in case it moves
in Bosnia and arming them arming their
people because the Bosnian leadership
was saying it's not many times they
repeated this it is not our war it is
war between Croatia and Serbia you know
which is very naive man you know your
neighbor is you know being attacked in
Croatia and being killed and slaughtered
and raped and and you are saying it's a
war between them has war between them
and not you
hey that has a potential to come over
into Bosnia what are you doing about
about it are you preparing yourself or
to defend yourself you have a right to
defend yourself so get armed you had a
ten months yeah they didn't do nothing
mm-hmm I want to go I want to go back
just briefly we're almost out of time a
few more points but when I was saying
like Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him where he clearly
said there's no killing of innocent men
women children amongst people priests of
people I'm sorry people in places of
worship tearing down places of worship
all destruction noticed property yeah
and our trees yeah it's it's amazing you
see you see these things clearly
outlined and then on the other side you
see some of the most horrific evil
happening and it saddens the heart you
know that these things have happened and
again I reiterate this is not to stir up
you know because many people they'll
take this the
incidents and try to you know use this
as fuel and fire to create animosity is
that what yeah some people benefit from
that it could be economically could be
you know position wise to keep their you
know power and all this so people will
do things like that you know but that's
not our intention here today that this
is clearly not our intention it's like I
said is to revisit to create awareness
and you were you got inspired there was
a there was an imam who actually because
the ceremony said the the anniversary
was like a few weeks ago right yes and
there was a there was an imam and local
Imam who was talking about it's kind of
touched you can you can you talk about
the points that he had mentioned yeah
you see the July 11th is the date that
you know people try to remember what
happened in reverence and that's that's
the day when servants are felt to the
Serbs and then during the next like next
24 to 48 hours over 2,000 people have
been slaughtered you know that's how
extensive and quick and brutal hit it
was and then in the next five to five to
seven days there was another over 5,000
people have been killed and slaughtered
on the way as they were trying to escape
from Schreber answer towards our Tuzla
now during this Imam al Rahman he was
talking about at that time he was like
17 18 and he was very young and he one
of his assignments was as a reporter to
go to Tuzla Airport and report about
these people coming from servants and he
said you know he will never forget some
of the things that he saw how these
people were arriving they were going
through the hilly moody mountains
you know four days trying to escape from
servants or two to a safe area in Tuzla
it's like a some sixties some kilometers
okay and it took him days and he will
see people you know they were scared
they were hungry they were their clothes
were torn they were without shoes with
he was just a you know terrible
situation you know yeah have you heard
people who have gone through it and
survived because anything that has
happened because tasks are fee like that
you know an evil like this usually there
are good ultimately you can see some
people they don't see but sometimes you
know some evil might happen in your life
but then a greater good happens right so
God out of his ultimate wisdom he allows
certain things that happen for a greater
good and we see a lot of people have you
talked to him that before this happened
they really weren't focusing on they
weren't serious in life they really were
just you know living life without any
purpose but this really this this
tragedy forced them to wake up to see
that man I can you know all this can
these blessings can be taken away I need
to take life seriously follow me yeah
well a lot of people before this
conflict you know in Bosnia they were
basically running after the material
world okay and neighbors were competing
with neighbors you know who is gonna
have a better car who's gonna have a
bigger house and things like that very
little attention was given to the to the
creator and what will happen when I die
you know and so during this conflict a
lot of people realize look you know they
were happy they didn't carry they lost
everything you know all the material
possessions as long as they save their
head their life mmm
you know so many of them realized and
many turned back to God and and became
good believers you know but then some of
some of those once the conflict conflict
stopped they turned back to the old ways
you know yeah but a lot of them stayed
there are true to to what they turned
back to you know they became good
Muslims good believers and they stayed
on that path yeah they learned a lesson
and but some some will never learn their
lesson until it is too late do Orthodox
Christians from that area do they know
and that was our lack of educating do
they know that we as Muslims love Jesus
do they know that we believe in how the
mighty messenger do they know that there
are so many commonalities between us uh
yeah I doubt it because even you doubt
that they know that I I doubt they know
that maybe some maybe there are priests
probably know that but they don't teach
them about it yeah because it's not in
their interest okay they will probably
lose the job do they so I mean even many
Muslims in Bosnia don't know that you
know if you mention Jesus it's like wow
you know you know it's like and they
don't realize that Jesus was just
another great prophet of God you know
and and that he was also a Muslim and
teaching Islam and teaching message of
submitting your will to the will of God
the whole prophets were teaching same
message and and so many your will to the
will of God you went translated in
arabic is means islam that's all it is
right you know yes so you know so and
you cannot be a muslim unless you
believe in all prophets of God including
Jesus you know yeah you can't be or if
Muslims are learning their faith okay
and practicing their faith and then
teaching others non-muslims you know
that we love Jesus maybe the
relationship would be better with other
Muslim people mm-hmm because they will
realize hey they also Revere respect and
love Jesus just like we you know yeah we
just don't worship them as a god or
literal son of God right because jesus
never called people to worship himself
but he called people to worship God and
and that that's amazing
because that's what I'm talking about
the internal right to be sincere with
ourselves and look internally what we
need to we need some adjustments we need
to make some adjustments and start
living really submission to the will of
God right now forgetting our Creator
right and then wondering you know
calamities happen and then what what do
you expect yeah and and you know
probably all Christians in in you know
in in former Yugoslavia don't realize
that Jesus was a Muslim yeah
we're almost out of time you you you you
told me once that the Bosnians there
they had they were called before the
buh-buh-buh what was it called Bosnians
the history of bosnian bosnian muslims
goes back to like 7th century when when
one group of Christians Orthodox
Christians from Bulgaria to avoid the
persecution because they were they were
believing that their their belief was
very close to the Islamic belief like
like those early Christians you know
that follow the message of Jesus very
closely so and they believed in one God
and also on on some of their tombstones
there was a moon and and and and and you
know just like Muslims have a bow or
crescent and so they moved from Bulgaria
West to Oh Bosnia into mountainous in
Bosnia is a three-quarter mountainous
country so they were they were they were
being called Bogomils bog means God and
Mill deer so they were called people
dear to God and the Catholics from
Croatia were
constantly attacking them and trying to
cut a catalyst ice them make them
Catholics and then they from from East
they're Serbs were attacking I'm trying
to make them Orthodox Christians they
resisted that successfully by moving
into mountains and defending themselves
then when the Ottoman when the Turks
came the Ottoman Empire and especially
Sultan Al Fatiha
he brought Islam to Bosnia back in 15th
century and there were they and and and
they were very tolerant of these people
in that they found in Bosnia and they
allowed them to practice their way their
religion and and you know they were did
enough force them to become Muslims so
when when these BOGO Mila saw how
tolerant Turks were with them they are
voluntarily embraced Islam there are
cases that are you know on one field in
one day over 60,000 of these people
embraced Islam this is in history in
history documented well you know so most
of the Muslims in Bosnia come from
Bogomils yeah and from from these people
that came from Bulgaria and then some
are from the from the Turks that stayed
in Bosnia okay when the Turkish Ottoman
retreated back to Turkey after 1878
barrel in Congress okay
and then some our local people you know
Catholics or Orthodox Christians that
embrace the Islam because they believe
in their message or they want to keep
their position you know in their society
yeah so but those are minority numbers
you know
and these extremist Serbs they hate
these Muslims and they column our
traders you know they believe that they
that Muslims before were Orthodox
Christians that embraced Islam
when they you know Ottoman Empire came
into the Balkans but we were just
following the the the organic the true
way of Jesus and Moses and Abraham they
all submitted their will to God that's
all we're doing now if there's there are
a lot of because the the the the message
of pure monotheism it resonates with the
heart and if there's what advice and we
got to curtail it we got to cut it we
went a little bit over time but for any
Serbian for any creation any purse like
from that part of the world who's not
stuck on it okay
Islam doesn't call you to you know if
you become a Muslim tomorrow do you have
to stop being a Serb no you're still a
sir but your you are your ethnicity is
Serbian yes okay if they're if they want
to write it Nissa tea is syrup but
nationalism is serbian yeah okay so if
they want to be right with God they
don't believe that Jesus are praying to
Jesus and many people reject this right
but they just kind of go along with the
flow they're like I don't believe you
know Jesus died for my sins I don't
believe that he was the literal son of
God but I believe in the God that Jesus
worship and I like this concept but
worshipping the crater not the creation
you know and I want to look into more of
the life a problem Ahamed I believe he
was the final message they did a little
research or they watch some of the Deen
shows and and what advice but you know
what it's very difficult I had we had a
individuals name as good a moment much
as last name and others who have spent a
little time with Muslims and they it
connects because the message is
believable it's based on proof but they
get a lot of backlash from the community
what advice do you have for them well
you know I told these people I let's
analyze and see what Jesus was doing you
know and I say you know this and let's
see who is better Christian you or me
they said how can you be a better
Christian when you are a Muslim you know
how can you be a better Christian to me
and when you are Muslim I say well let's
analyze this let me ask you a few
questions who did Jesus pray to and they
say he prayed to God okay I said okay
who do you pray to who took most of the
Christians pray to most of them pray to
Jesus then how did Jesus pray you know
you know there are pictures of him I
mean that pictures about drawings of him
kneeling down on the ground on his
forehead and on palms of hands praying
okay that's how he was praying and how
Muslims prayed that's how Muslims prayed
you know and and Christians pray on
their knees or standing you know and
then I asked him okay
did Jesus where Jesus circumcised yes he
was the eighth day okay and all of his
disciples were circumcised you know and
uh you know and all early Christians
were circumcised now all Muslim boys get
circumcised duh you know and but most
Christians don't get circumcised
especially like in in in in these you
know Serbs and and other people you know
they don't believe in that the
difference is in Western countries where
they practice hygiene okay yeah then I
asked him okay did Jesus our eat pork
you know they say no you know they know
that you know and I say yeah okay
Muslims don't eat pork okay but most
Christians eat pork so how do you agree
people and yes that's another thing I
asked them I said you know what was his
greeting ah they don't know it was a
Shalom Aleichem which you can check this
it's in in Luke chapter 24 verse 36 and
you can verify this yourself okay and
Muslims greet each other Salam alaikum
which means peace be upon you so what do
you know and but Christians don't don't
say Salam alaikum to each other peace be
with you you know
so you see Muslims are doing all they
are they are actually following
teachings of Jesus they doing what he's
doing saying what he is saying God is
calling yeah the ocean yeah Muslims are
not who you know Jesus is not worshiping
himself now he was teaching his
followers to worship God who created him
yes but why most Christians are
worshipping Jesus when he did not
worship himself yeah he not following
his teachings you know
so Muslims are following all of his
teachings you know who is better a
Christian now if if if we decide that
you know if we decide that you know
according to the machine according to
what your following are you following
teachings of Jesus then you know Muslims
who follow his teachings they are you
know better Christians that then
Christians because they not following
his teachings this is just very
interesting it's even translated because
he spoke Aramaic that he called on God
by name Aloha Allah Allah ha this is it
so if anyone sincere they'll see the
truth is they're in submission to the
will of God which is Islam and a Muslim
is something one like you said who
submits their will to God and Arabic the
Christians they they call God Allah yeah
this is it ok so so a person if he's
Serbian Croatian whatever first date
would you say they got to be sincere
with God and not just be worried about
the national because that's not
nationalism not going to save you on a
day of judgment if they say they are
following a they are they are good
Christians then they should be honest
with it they should find really what
Jesus was teaching and followed his
message and and and not following what
church is teaching them yeah because you
know church is teaching them things that
many things that Jesus did not teach and
there are contradictory to teachings of
Jesus is Islam open to all the
Christians is it open to all the
creation is it open front they can
accept at any time yes yes and anybody
is welcome to learn about Islam and to
embrace and submit their will to will of
God yeah
I want to thank you very much we're
under this was a very exciting show
again reiterating revisiting not to
forget so we can help prevent this
genocide which was the greatest genocide
on European soil after World War two
last closing comments and suggestions
for for the people listening who are out
there and they have you know many
they've been affected by the hate
machine they hear a lot of negative
things about Islam
you know what do you what do you like to
tell people who have been affected by
the hate machine well I would say that
they need to do their own research and
find the truth and one of the reasons
why God sent us to this earth is to
improve relationships with each other
and to help each other and we should
work on that dr. Joseph itch
thank you very much follows just a bit
least nama know my program thank you
very pleasurable forgiveness for our
shortcomings honey and hopefully this
will be useful information and it will
stimulate those who don't know about
this situation to do a little more of
their own research and to learn a little
bit more about it and maybe help in
future to prevent such things whatever
it is I mean thank you so much and thank
you for tuning in to the D show and I
hope you got to benefit revisiting this
history so we're gonna prevent God
willing through awareness something
tragic like this I'm Eva like this
happening again and if you're a syrup
you're Croatian whoever you are out
there Islam is open for all of mankind
you just got to be sincere with yourself
and ask the owner the creator of mankind
for guidance start there and continue to
tune in every week here to the Deen show
and we'll see you next time if you have
any questions concerns call us
Allah Allah
there's only one word in Muhammad is His
Messenger
Allah Allah
[Music]